after more than a week of intense
speculation and anticipation Manhattan
district attorney Alvin Bragg leaves his
office in New York having just made
history minutes later a spokesperson
confirmed that a grand jury Bragg
convened had voted to indict former
president Donald Trump over alleged hush
money to a former adult film star and
that prosecutors were working out the
arrangements with Trump's lawyers for
the former president to turn himself
into authorities
it wasn't long before a typically
combative Trump responded through a post
on social media Trump calling the
indictment an attack on our country the
likes of which has never been seen
before Stormy Daniels and her alleged
sexual encounter with Donald Trump is at
the center of the criminal case against
the former president after she
threatened to go public about the affair
in the final days of Trump's 2016
presidential campaign Trump's then fixer
Michael Cohen paid her a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars to keep quiet
Cohen who testified before the grand
jury has said he made the payments at
Trump's Direction and in 2018 pleaded
guilty to violating campaign Finance
laws it's not Revenge right what this is
is about accountability I don't want to
see anyone including Donald Trump
indicted prosecuted convicted
incarcerated simply because I
fundamentally disagree with them this is
all about accountability he needs to be
held accountable for his Dirty Deeds
Trump has always denied the affair and
also initially denied any knowledge of
the payment but now says it took place
as a legitimate legal expense
[Music]
under New York law it is the
falsification of business records not
the payment itself that would be Trump's
crime a misdemeanor and only if
prosecutors can prove he made the
payment and falsified records
specifically to hide the affair from
voters or the IRS would it be a felony
or a more serious crime that could come
with jail time the falsification of
records for the purpose of committing
tax evasion would be the additional
specific crime to elevate falsification
of business records from a misdemeanor
to a felony the exact charges against
Donald Trump in the indictment are still
under seal and have not made public it's
expected early next week Trump will
arrive here in New York to turn himself
into authorities he'll then face a judge
and then be released Trump is the first
current or former president of the
United States states to ever face
criminal charges
Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera New York